this week 48 Hours investigates the
mysterious death of a popular professor
at the University of Georgia in May 2019
Professor Marianne Shockley and her
boyfriend Marcus Lillard went to their
friend's house to swim and listen to
music the friend's name is Clark heindel
hours later he was dead and so was
Marianne only her boyfriend Marcus was
still alive for eight hours contributor
Jonathan bigliotti looks at what
happened
we got a good one here we got a call
about the woman being underwater for a
minute or two don't touch nothing no no
leave that around that don't say nothing
it was the early morning of May 12 2019.
we're gonna rope it off and go from
there
and Medics and Sheriff deputies rushed
to a house in Milledgeville Georgia the
initial report was that a woman had
drowned in a hot tub
Marcus Lillard identified the woman in
the hot tub as his girlfriend college
professor Dr Marianne Shockley we get
out here
and something ain't right with this so
can I get your name please or Clark
heindel owned the property where
Marianne died Marcus said he and
Marianne had gone there to socialize had
a few beers smoked a little pot started
a list of some music had a couple more
beers Marcus says he and Marianne but
not Clark got into the hot tub he
initially told deputies he then left her
to collect some firewood as I dropped
the wood off at the fireplace I could
see Marianne slump down my mother called
me and she said Marianne's gone and I
just was saying no Mama no no
Ayla Crippen is Marianne's sister she's
drowned in some hot tub and I was like
Marianne is not stupid she would not
drown in a hot tub yeah something funny
with this somebody it ain't adding up
deputies suspected a possible homicide
and that was before a shotgun went off
inside the
by morning of the three people who
attended the small party only Marcus was
still alive there is good and there is
evil and that night evil came to play
[Music]
Jonathan vigliotta joins us right now um
no we're like wait wait do people die
and there was a shotgun yeah what it's a
complicated story wow Jonathan so what
did the investigators find out about
what actually happened yeah and it's a
good question I think to start off this
was a party of just three people only
one person walked away alive it's hard
perhaps to ever understand the truth
here authorities believe they do know
the truth based on the evidence the
medical examiner releasing a report that
showed indicated stringulation marks on
Marianne's neck they presented that
evidence in a trial and ultimately it
did not sway the jury who acquitted
Marcus we sat down with Marcus an
exclusive interview three hours the
entire time he maintained his innocence
what's his defense
he says that it gets even stranger it
all surrounds a hot tub he disappeared
for a period of time came back that's
when he says that Marianne was found
with water up to the brim of her nose he
says they did a lot of drugs that night
they were drinking a lot of alcohol they
were in a hot tub that was hotter than
it should be Marianne had an enlarged
heart all these are facts but the
autopsy shows you said strangulation so
strangulation those were those were
marks that were found on her neck so the
question is if there was strangulation
involved as the autopsy reveals who did
it what about the cargo and that's the
third person here so he's the owner of
the home where this party took place he
took his life shortly after police
arrived on scene many people including
the defense pointed to that as a
possible indication that he could have
been responsible in some way others
though say it's very easy to point
fingers at a person who can't defend
himself not alive to talk so a very
complicated story one where when you
hear all three sides of it you still
wonder what exactly I pulled it all
right John be glad to have you here at
the table yeah not wearing the yellow
fire jacket out there yeah all right
different suit today I see Jonathan's
report the strange death of Professor
Shockley on 48 hours tomorrow night at
10 9 Central here on CBS and streaming
on Paramount plus we'll be right back